[Musique]
mon rôle c'est de préparer défilé aérien
depuis sa conception sur papier savoir
quelles qu'elles
quel avion on va mettre dans le défilé
donc l ordre on va les faire défiler
ça passe par aujourd'hui une répétition
grandeur nature à chaque fois
[Musique]
il faut compter six mois pour pour
commencer à sur une feuille de papier
blanc à concevoir le défilé jusqu'aux
jusqu'à l'exécution de change alors sur
un défilé aérien comme ça c'est à peu
près 300 hommes qui sont mobilisés aussi
bien dans les avions qui défilent au sol
pour les contrôleurs aériens ou pour les
pour la mécanique
[Musique]
et c'est un peu plus de 60 appareils se
sont avions et
un peu moins de 30 hélicoptères des
leaders
felli danse
[Musique]
pour
non
la capitaine hélène donc je suis entré
dans l'armée de l'air en 2006 je suis
capitaine depuis 2015 et je suis pilote
d'hélicoptère sur le fennec qu'on peut
voir dernier
le fennec donc c'est un saint mais les
coquilles et bimoteurs c'est un petit
hélico moderne quand même des années 90
c'est un hélico qui est assez polyvalent
peut faire énormément de choses avec
[Musique]
il a un inconvénient c'est que
il manque peut-être un petit peu de
puissance
le dp ça donc c'est un dispositif
particulier de sûreté aérienne
c'est vraiment l'établissement d'une
bulle de sécurité aérienne autour d'un
événement particulier dont classe avec
le 14 juillet donc on protège
l'événement on protège les autorités qui
participent à ces événements
bon
non
ç'a vraiment imaginer une bulle une
bulle étanche il ya des avions des
hélicoptères en fait on participe à tous
les niveaux de vitesse donc
de basses vitesses à très haute vitesse
et on protège d'espacé on empêche toute
intrusion dans l'espace aérien pendant
l'événement ce 14 juillet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mission principale sur les fennecs c'est
d'assurer la sûreté aérienne
on a une alerte h 24 on protège les
frontières on protège l'espace aérien
protège des zones interdites les zones
étatique
paris laisse fin vraiment où toute la
france on est divisé en à un escadron
jumeaux à orange et donc par ces deux
escadrons on sécurise
[Musique]
car demander aux hôpitaux
la principale qualité c'est la
dissociation d'attention la coordination
parce que vous avez pu voir que en a
plusieurs commandes il faut réfléchir
vite avoir du bon sens et de la
dissociation d'attention
[Applaudissements]
défilé qui s'est déroulé devant des
gradins cardinal n'a pas de bons points
particuliers abordés on aura pris
également la qualité du travail fourni
par tous le monde autant à la
préparation d'élections
merci à vous la sécurité n'a jamais été
engagée après mon coin on sait déjà
qu'il n'y aura pas d'entraînement
supplémentaire demain vous pourrez
rentrer chez eux à l'issue du dmfu de
l'après midi
[Applaudissements]